that doesn't mean that we point our
fingers at someone say you need to take
ownership because as we know when you do
that people get defensive you know you
go and you say hey look I failed to make
sure that I understood this task
do you mind next time if I give you a
quick read back of what I think the task
is to make sure that I understand it but
so I'm taking full ownership like this
is on me I need to do this now there's
also a chance and she goes yeah cool you
you should do that whatever
pay more attention in which case right
so she's not taking any ownership she's
like yeah you should have and now like
wait a second extreme ownership's not
supposed to work like that yes it is
when you take ownership of the problem
and I go you know what I should have
asked you a question she goes yeah you
should have and you go yep exactly
that's what I just said and now you ask
questions and now you make sure you
fully understand the task and now the
problem solved